let me go next to our friend
maddie from evanston illinois maddie uh
what's uh what's going on with you
what's on your mind today and you uh
you are on
you can go ahead i i see you've unmuted
but we can't hear you
might be a an issue of microphone
selection
all right maddie just i'll give you one
more opportunity there you are maddie
oh awesome hi david um first of all
thank you so much for all that you do
you're giving me such a reality check
right now and i really appreciate that
good um second of all i you know after
watching last night tonight's debate i
i can't help but wonder how
in the hell the right is like framing
this
and like how they could possibly think
that like
trump might have won the debate like i'm
trying to get into that mindset
and i like simply can't and i'm
wondering if you could like give me any
more insight into that
so basically there's two sets of people
that are defending trump there's people
saying that trump
actually won because biden stuttered
right so there's that group that's
basically just saying that you know
trump just won
there are people and an earlier caller
identified it
um who are conceding or see
implicitly conceding that trump didn't
do so well and he was unhinged in this
stuff
but they're essentially blaming chris
wallace and saying chris wallace was
part of like a fake news media cabal to
give trump the tough questions and to
challenge
trump more and that it was all rigged
against donald trump those are the main
two lines of defense now for me they
both ring hollow
but the point is all that really matters
is what the independents thought and and
by maddie
i don't know if you're listening to
something else in the background or that
if that's my own voice feeding back but
maybe we could do something about it
any better now that is better yeah okay
all right yeah i mean that's crazy but
but
uh helpful to frame it in that way and
um i guess my other question is like
how do i restore my faith
in this democratic process when uh you
know
the leadership is telling me that like
you know if
it goes the way that he doesn't want it
to go then we're all
like screwed and anarchy will reign etc
etc so in the
in the immediate 30 it's horrifying in
the immediate 30 however many days we
have left
in the immediate 30 or however many days
we have left what we have to do
is just overwhelm the vote and try to
get the biggest victory possible
if and when we do that then we can talk
about fixing these other systemic issues
which have been exposed including that
our checks and balances really only work
if somebody enforces them and what we've
learned under donald trump is if nobody
enforces them they don't really do much
for us
yeah all right matty it sounds like
you've got a lot going on there so i'm
gonna let you go but i really appreciate
you talking to me all right thanks so
much
take care all right there's maddie
maddie having a very very busy day there
okay guys uh a success the first day
taking calls on discord the
call quality was stunning and i really
appreciate everybody who got in touch we
will do it again next week